ho cercato di risalire la
[Musica]
[Applauso]
scarpata all'ospedale infestato insomma
così nuovissima e schifo orbita per
quelle obi sa non è più belle e uscito
nove skip room in cui dovremo scappare
dall'ospedale fa la libido di zombie ai
brani che probabili qui siamo scappati
dal dottore pazzo medico patto come
stavo testi sono anche gli zombie come
ti permetti tv come di pre di pop corn
ho qualcosa da mangiare qualcosa da bere
e lasciate un bel mi piace qui sotto e
di teolo subita non esiste più
l'esperimento scientifico è fallito è
poi noi che si sono trasformati in
zombie dobbiamo scappare o villa è già
scappato di una crisi che del dottore
che sta per tagliare un paziente che è
diventato uno zombie zombie qui dicevano
l'elettricità lo vuole aspettare è uno
l'esperimento è fallito dice il dottore
è sì se ne siamo accorti ma perché vuoi
affettarlo poverino come si fa a saltare
dai no anche a me ha fatto a pezzi i
evitassimo sfracellati nello stand
69 tutto da capo ok riproviamo dai non
farti distrarre da king dal medico che
sta aspettando lo zombie allora vedi
bene adesso una volta quasi all'ultimo
check è finito male allora sembra che
qui dobbiamo saltare su queste lettini
[Musica]
come destro vita e si sfracella acqua
importante che arrivò prima vi piace il
mio nuovo cerchietto con il fiocchetto
vediamo se ci seguite bene se fate parte
della redazione
family dove ho trovato questo sacchetto
in quale video che rimangono nei
commenti qui su per voi ma se uno zombie
mista il soffitto sono fatta così
ora qui dobbiamo saltare su questo
stetoscopio mi sa gigante ttt ma ti
posso spingere giù un altezza
ea tutta
così vari quest'arma vorrebbe spingersi
e ti sei sfracellato today caso dal
karma
nostri trovo perché perché devi andare
con calma
vediamo agli sfracella menti di vitale e
mali cielo di zombie che ha vomitato
davvero tutta questa cosa perde vomita
di zombie weidmann lonero vaticane serie
ha detto ma ci sono dei muri molto
affilati passati sotto mi stai copiando
è vitale vista superando gli zombie
hanno aperto un portale per un tutto
molto strano dobbiamo parlare d'acqua
dal portale ma
a volte bisogna correre saltare la corsa
si sa che cosa c'entra questo per una
spesa di zombie
[Musica]
vabbè l'importante è sempre superare in
che cosa è sfracellato la sotto i massi
per un'auto fisicamente può che vuole
mandar soli no non so da che parte
possiamo evitarlo dobbiamo per forza
mentre mangiate
aspetto visto arrivato vediamo vita
consob ci piace
ma ci deve mangiare lo zombie non
bastava il primato così non scoprirà si
no ne ho mangiato
quindi l'unica strada ma questo zombie
prima non aveva i denti alessio a tutta
una dentatura perfetta di un po strano
ho realizzato adesso che conta che ci ho
pensato
che ci ha mangiato lo zombie adesso
è che dobbiamo passare da quella parte
lì e vitale express e la mente numero
253 mila
questo zombie fatto in modo un po strano
infatti un modo diverso rispetto agli
altri c'è chi come sei perché macchiata
rosa e rosse ma se questa è la gola ma
dovessere io perché non ti vedo più si
giova sopra mostra venendo qua da un
peso zombie agli scalini c'è il cuore
questo che lo zombie dopo gli scalini
cioè il cuore
come facciamo passare qui non lo so
forse disegno prenderei
dove sarà anche vitale si sfracella che
guarda solo qui s'è bloccato fuoco non
si credo sono anche amore non è caduto
vai ci credeva più volte in tanto
qualche trucchetto mandò sono proprio
bravissimo
non è possibile che ancora non è
precipitato perché dovrei guarda foto
sono bravo sono già al prossimo livello
di testa diventata brava nel parkour
decreto c'è c'è uno scheletro qui non so
se fa parte dello zombie
costole queste sono le coste le materie
insegnate parlato da sotto ma dobbiamo
passare qui è molto complicato devo dire
ho capito forse queste strisce rosse
sono le bene vitale
sinistra cella mesi come fatto salire la
sopra i cieli e superiamo vitale il mio
prende il belgio binario primo amore no
mi sta sprigionando senza ma noi
proviamo a
prenderti ma come si deve fare si deve
essere inteso ovviamente
perdiamo dove credi di scappare ci sono
anch'io qui
siamo tirati dietro dello zombie
beh almeno non abbiamo fatto abbiamo la
palla poi siamo scappati dello zombie
fino a calcio lo chiamo di tornare
all'ospedale e
non patente per leggere attenzione il
pavimento è la famosa la lo direi posso
continuare i farmaci ma difficilissimo
devi arrampicarti su quella da
e viva vitale superato sto arrivando e
questo che cos'è dovrò saltare
piano
io sono un po rimasto bloccato qui
ho cercato di salire non ci riescono
[Musica]
[Applauso]
si
dai facciamo tutte le tipo per evitare
le alzate un bivio cieco è stato per
portare fortuna si può trovare portatemi
funziona c'è un fuoco
siamo tornati nell'ospedale davvero
qualcosa mi dice che alla fine dovremo
affrontare il medico zombie pazzo lo
scienziato
ecco altro vomito di zombie che tifo
l'italia ancora non non compare che mi
fa pensare
non si è sfracellato un'altra volta
attenzione evita il vomito di zombie
ecco
l'ospedale si sta distruggendo stai
attento perché la lava ed immortale ma
vado avanti
no
sono il vantaggio si fa raggiungere vita
chiusi ha superato lorenzo dove sono già
avantissimo guarda anzi credo
perché non ci devi chiedere scusa perché
0 e displasia gli dissi mila volte e ma
questi zombie sono sul soffitto e
continuano a vomitare
testo di legge è un fatto subito numero
ecco qui
[Musica]
c'è uno zombie po arrabbiato qui alla
rompendo il vetro
penso che dobbiamo andare quando fare
qui c'è un ascensore
sali sopra in cima e devi saltare dentro
all'ascensore aperto o
no che cosa è accaduto e non capisce
secondo me dobbiamo saltare qui e poi di
quale guarda seguire anzi no chi li
prende tutti
siamo super in atto siamo quasi a
evitare che adesso è l'aver ci stavo
quasi ci stavo quasi per riuscire guarda
che ti fai un bel po e adesso dobbiamo
andare forse qui sia di salire
sull'ascensore questione questa
l'ascensore
[Applauso]
ok dove siamo nuovo dell'ascensore e
gigante bisogna avere di qua e vitali
maser
è diventato
è diventato più complicata questa
station molto e poi se un mix di cose
tipo o da con la terna infatti laser con
le ossa proprio che ci saranno queste
ossa poi del il
no dei pazienti che che opera lo
scienziato pazzo vitale e avaro rilancio
ma questa può camminare su questa base
si ma perchè devo
prendere il bel sì allora proviamo
andare più
piano e che bisogna mantenere
l'equilibrio
ce la fai la siamo fatta e tu dove sei
io l'ho già finito questa parte siamo
super in alto
ora però
ecco vitale laggiù capo dalla vita
entra vita di yahoo ti aspetto qui dai
dai che ce la puoi farcela questa parte
superata ecco citeriore ossa solo queste
mattonelle rosse ti mancano mai
attenta nostra gel darti
ma perché saltando per salutarti
andiamo comitati zombie
torniamo cento zombie col anno porta
meno male la porta è chiusa fratto
approfitti della mia non solo per
superarmi allora apriamo l'ascensore
cosa ci sarà nell'ascensore
hai già preso l'ascensore
fissatelo trasportando anche a te eccoci
siamo ritornati dentro l'ospedale
sono degli zombie contiamo 6 fano ha
forse parlerà via d'uscita
il materasso dove andiamo
tutti
di sinistra giornata da tutti davis
presi alla rapina no perché sono troppo
bravo sto parlando con il mio amico
dottore che salì sul tetto della
tarantella 38 del brutto se non è
corretto sono in vantaggio ha detto sono
sicura che
forse perché bisogna stata dall'altra
parte ora lo aspetta
è passato prima io ho detto ok
ma perché parole stato troppo o troppo
o che forse sarò d'età beh quasi di
tutto
ei
indovina il bacio a tiscali esistono o
cremati sai forse adesso vitali si
sfracella è il mondo andata non mi
ricordo io spero di sì
ciao da evitare e preservati no
disastro celata chi dice di sfracellarsi
il progetto all'hotel non mi dire kate
avrebbe ben non ancora ma sono uno
spavento in vantaggio sarebbe bloccata
dai ti aspetto che sei un insieme ok il
sito luca la sveglia abbiamo anche poco
ancora ancora devi salire quella
torretta che tutte quelle scale e
un'altra scala si è poi un'altra anca
scala ancora in altissimo mare ci segua
sempre al cielo ecco noi vediamo che
dice il dottore poi vai sul suo cerchio
rosso per passare al prossimo per il
prossimo grattacielo
abbiamo parlato buono nessun altro che
da genova che bello adesso spider man ma
anche su questo grattacielo ci sono gli
zombie dei fatti non so perché sia fatta
andare qua forse la via d'uscita questo
ecco altri zombie che sono
già chicago via evviva finalmente
fare va data
no aspetta a stare lato
il tetto è molto scivoloso quindi
assicurati di saltare dall'altra parte a
parte
progettata in 10 mila pezzi indovinate
chi è in vantaggio è
riuscito a passare il tetto
è già in forza dai
e ora non sto trovando il peggio dove il
belgio siamo abbiamo finito credo
le 36 privati
[Applauso]
[Musica]
dell'ospedale in cui è stato di zombie
vice un pad verde per affrontare nuove
avventure
guardatele stato un mi piace
e ora vi lasciamo quarto altra casa the
lines criticare provvedere nostri altri
video su quella che preferite
ciao ciao